um I mean look Bible translations uh
which ones would you recommend and why
yeah this is a very good question and
it's a question I have to really tread
lightly and by the way the verse I want
to recommend to people Proverbs 18:17
should be one of the verses you etch in
your hearts your minds and write it on
the walls Proverbs 18:17 says the first
to present his case seems right until
his neighbor comes and questions
him right so anyone can make a powerful
persuasive case if you just leave them
alone but when you bring others to start
asking the right set of questions his
case might may not be as the only time
someone should be convinced of something
is if it stands the harshest the
toughest objections biblically that's
why no doubt Trinity is absolutely true
it's irrefutable Jesus being the God man
absolutely true irrefutable that the
Bible is divine and origin absolutely
true you a fful because it stands the
toughest objections and decimates them
so glory to the trying God for that but
I want your audience to remember
remember Proverbs 18:17 the first to
present us case seems right until
someone comes and questions him make
that your life verse and then 1
Thessalonians 5:21 which goes with it
first Thessalonians 5:21 test all things
hold fast to that which is good it's
right there now as far as Bible
translation is
concerned for the most part any English
translation
that's done by a committee of
trinitarian Scholars will give you a
faithful reproduction of God's word in
English because the manuscripts that
have been preserved by God we have
nearly we have nearly over 25,000 close
to 30,000 manuscript copies of the
different books of the Bible in various
languages some go even before Christ in
the case of the Old Testament like the
Dead Sea Scrolls we have copies of the
Hebrew Old Testament book with the
exception of Esther they haven't found
that yet that were uncovered 1947 that
written anywhere from 200 to 100 years
before Christ now as far as the New
Testament that comes after Christ we
have copies of New Testament from the
second century and then copious
citations of the church fathers from the
second century and not so the Bible
books are in a class all their own the
Mount of manuscript and textual
historical evidence for its preservation
is overwhelming
nothing even comes close to it when I'm
talking about nothing I'm talking about
books of antiquity or even medieval
period prior to the printing press even
Skeptics someone like aart will tell you
the manuscripts of the Bible are
ginormous there's no other book that has
as much manuscript and if you're going
to question its accurate preservation
throughout all the books of antiquity
and the medieval period down the drain
because they don't even come close so as
far as the preservation of God's words
they're there preserved nothing's
lost the problem is is
that you have certain
manuscripts that were discovered in the
1920 centuries that are from third
fourth fifth
centuries so these are probably our
oldest witnesses to the books of the
Bible the problem there is that though
they are early they have a higher degree
of disagreement now I have to be careful
when I say disagreement they're going to
think that means oh it changes the
message no it doesn't this is this is a
statement of fact you pick up a copy of
the Gospel of John written the second
century and you pick up a copy of the
Gospel of John written in the n9th
century 800s you're going to get the
same theology the same meaning the same
Jesus you're not going to get a
different theology but there are
differences because copyists do not copy
the same way and they don't make the
same mistakes so then how do we know
that the original preserved because if
you have nearly 30,000 copies this why I
have to tread lightly to explain this so
people don't misunderstand think we
can't trust the Bible we have nearly
30,000 copies that were written at
different times in different places and
spread all over the world no one person
no group of individuals had the
manuscripts in their possession to
corrupt it the way they wanted because
of that God ensured that we would know
what the originals were why because
let's say your copy in Rome written 300
ad John you have these Corruptions
mistakes or intentional Corruptions
but then we have 50 other copies written
before yours and after spread all over
all agree this is what this verse says
disagreeing with you so now we know okay
that's defective see this how God has
preserved it now the only problem is
modern scholarship likes to prioritize
the earlier papyri and codic vaticanus
what's called vaticanus and caticus cius
or cicus as someone pronounce it which
is from the 4th Century throughs ad even
though those copies will give you the
same message same gospel same Jesus as
reflected in your English translations
pick up an NIV which prioritizes these
early copies and compare it to your King
James over 90 3% of the time they
agree so I pick up John one it's going
to read the same way NIV it's going to
read it's over 90% about 93% of time to
98% of time some have different
statistics they agree so you're going to
get the same it's that either two to 7%
difference so with that said with all
that necessary qualification sorry sorry
Sam but nothing nothing uh changes the
core doctrines of the faith though no
it's a fact that's it's just a fact it's
a factual statement I'm not saying it's
not a statement of faith it's a
statement of fact that that's why when
you pick up NIV the only difference is
it's Modern English meaning that it's
not Elizabethan English thou and I but
you're going to get the same message and
pretty much over 90% of the time they're
translating the same
verses pick it up and I want people to
prove me wrong pick up NIV pick up King
James or pick up English Standard
Version New King James there are those
differences that even with those
differences you still don't get
different theology but however the issue
is should we prioritize these earlier
Witnesses or should we look into what's
known as the majority text the majority
text the reason why it's called majority
taex is because let's say because the
numbering for the Greek copies of New
Testament varies some will say 5,300
plus some say it's 5,900 let's go with
5,300 plus over
5,000 form a majority where they have a
very high degree of agreement over
against these fewer earlier copies so
let's say 5,300 we say 5,000 of them are
majority Texs the 300 are the earlier
copies from the 3D fourth fifth
centuries now these 5,000 have a much
higher degree of
agreement and they form their own what
they call textual line the majority text
also known as a Byzantine text the
reason why Scholars don't prioritize
them is because these readings the
earliest evidence that we have for them
are let's say from the 400s onwards then
they become the majority so because they
assert or assume that these
readings the evidence for them is not as
early as these other manuscripts
therefore these un manuscripts should be
prioritized and I say baloney why just
because you may have a stream that
doesn't have as early support for it you
still have to account for the fact that
these are copies of earlier copies so if
I have a copy in the 400s that's not the
original that means it's based on
something early
so that shows that these readings do go
back as far as we can trace it and
therefore should be prioritized so the
majority should be prioritized for that
reason secondly second
reason the church for the most part
until the discovery of the papyri
because these earlier copies were not
discovered until the 1800s 1900s so that
means up until that time what the
churches had access to were the majority
texts these were the man cripts that God
preserved and gave the church access to
and these are the manuscripts they
translated from God is Sovereign and
he's real we all agree if he is real and
he is and he is Sovereign and he is and
he loves his church and he does and he
wants to make sure the church has access
to the right set of manuscripts to
translate from if these earlier
Witnesses were Superior why then did he
allow them to be buried why didn't he
make sure these were the ones that the
church had access to obviously that
means the majority textas what God was
pleased with if he's pleased with it
that means we need to prioritize those
manuscripts and go with those and when
they disagree with the early ones the
early ones are to be set
aside so that leads me to the third
point the translations today that are
based on the majority text the Byzantine
text majority of our Witnesses are the
King James version the new King James
and Modern English version so when you
ask me what do I prefer because I'm
convinced the majority texts is superior
from which we we got What's called the
texus receptus the receive text which is
a smaller number of Greek manuscripts
that were collated starting with arasmus
in the 16th century which comes out of
the majority of witnesses from which
then the King James was produced I
prioritize these translations and I
prefer the King James for one reason one
reason and I'm not saying people should
follow me this is my journey because for
over 300 years and even up to now now
the King James Bible for over 300 years
was the translation for all English
speaking Christians all over the world
and had no competition when did the King
James started slowly disappearing from
being that prominent in the 20th century
from the 1950s onward when a plethora of
modern versions were produced so that
today the two best-selling Bible
translations NIV and King James King
James is still a bestseller now in some
surveys NIV sells better but that's
because NIV has more Publishers and
societies promoting it less than the
King James does so the King James
doesn't have the the publicity or the
money spent to promote it and it's still
the bestselling Bible next to the NIV
wow so for me I start with God what do I
mean I start with God who's Almighty he
is who is faithful and good and he is
and who's Sovereign because I start with
that as a
given I must assume that God would not
allow a translation to be the chief
unparallel translation for
English-speaking Christians for over 300
years if he didn't approve of its
readings right I'm not an agnostic I'm
not an atheist I know God is real and
he's faithful and he loves his church
and he wants the bride of Christ to have
a sure word that they know this is the
voice of Our Lord UND undiluted
well that was the King James even up to
now therefore when modern Scholars
textual critics tell me there are
defective readings in the King James
that should be ignored my question to
them is did God know they were
defective yes and does God want to make
sure that his church do not quote
readings that were not part of the
original autographs that were later
added yes so then why did he make the
King James the chief translation based
on manuscripts that you claim have
verses that were added later whether
accidentally or intentionally that
shouldn't be there where was God to
protect this church no I'm sorry I can't
I can't accept that and
interestingly the Orthodox Church's
official Greek text is a Byzantine text
a majority text they do not follow the
earlier papyri for them it's a majority
text that's why when you go to an
Orthodox Church don't take my word for
this in the Pew you'll either find the
new King James version or the king James
version they don't
use and the Orthodox Church doesn't use
the Hebrew Old Testament it uses the
Greek versions called the yeah there you
go y I personally use the uh King James
uh sorry the new King James not because
I don't want to use the King James but I
struggle a little bit I struggle a
little bit with the uh Elizabeth and so
but um let me add further cave because
you said that if someone has our time
understanding Elizabeth in English the
Bible is to be understood and lived out
it's not just to be read just like uh
it's it's meant to be understood so you
can know God and love him and Obey him
because Jesus says he who loves me keeps
my word if a translation is hard for you
to understand hard for you to read then
you won't know God truly you won't know
his will you won't be able to act upon
it so if the new King James is difficult
because a lot of people even have a hard
time with that Modern English version is
difficult then I would even advise for
those people who are on a journey start
with the NIV start with the for now read
it so you can understand it once you
understand it and you're comprehension
of English language improves then work
your way up to Elizabethan
English but don't get hung up on you no
no I'd rather have you like Paul said
I'd rather speak five words clearly than
10,000 words in a tongue that you don't
understand